♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
Former President Trump
on Saturday said
that the 2020 election
should be overturned
and the Constitution
should be terminated.
Well, I'll say this for him --
he does give a memorable
wedding toast.
[ Laughter ]
Tomorrow is
the Georgia Senate runoff,
and unfortunately,
Herschel Walker's vote
isn't going to count.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden said on Friday
the Democrats must win
the Georgia Senate runoff
to avoid
a 50/50 split in the chamber.
"But that would mean the end
of my presidency,"
said Joe Manchin.
[ Laughter ]
After she was kicked off
a Spirit Airlines flight,
former New Jersey governor
Chris Christie's niece,
Shannon Epstein,
reportedly injured six deputies
while resisting arrest,
including kicking an officer
in the groin, which can only
mean one thing.
She's running.
[ Laughter ]
During last night's reception
at the White House
for Kennedy Center honorees,
President Biden praised
the band U2 and said their music
has "changed the world."
Damn, I knew Biden was old, but
I didn't know he was that old.
[ Laughter ]
New York City recently posted
a job listing
for a Director of
Rodent Mitigation,
which will pay up to
$170,000 a year.
Wow, 170 grand a year to say,
"Maybe don't serve dinner
in the gutter?"
[ Laughter ]
"Might that mitigate?"
According to the latest numbers,
crime on New York's subway
last month decreased by 13%
because it's hard
to commit a crime
if you can't move your arms.
[ Laughter ]
Rapper Bad Bunny was named
Spotify's most streamed artist
worldwide in 2022.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No word yet on what he's doing
with his $6.
[ Laughter ]
A tortoise named Jonathan
that lives on the island of
St. Helena recently celebrated
his 190th birthday
with his 140-year-old
trophy wife.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone's laughing at you,
Jonathan!
And finally, amid the chaotic
pre-sale for Taylor Swift's
The Eras tour, more than
two dozen fans recently filed
a lawsuit against Ticketmaster's
parent company, Live Nation,
for unlawful conduct.
And while a trial is still
a long ways off,
pre-sale tickets
are already available.
[ Laughter ]
Today is the Georgia
Senate runoff,
and there's only one candidate
in the race
who definitely knows that.
[ Laughter ]
Georgia Republican Senate
candidate Herschel Walker said
during a rally over the weekend
that he doesn't know
what a pronoun is.
And someone said, "It's what you
call your illegitimate kids."
And he said, "Oh, them?"
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Herschel Walker
said at a rally over the weekend
that he doesn't know
what a pronoun is.
Okay, it cannot be good for
Raphael Warnock's self-esteem
that this is a close race.
I mean, imagine
seeing your opponent
basically eating paste
on TV every night
and knowing he might win.
[ Laughter ]
When asked yesterday about
former President Trump
calling for the termination
of the Constitution,
Nebraska Senator Ben Sasse
asked if Republicans
"want to keep giving oxygen to
someone who is trying to sell
tickets to his own
proprietary circus,
or do they want to be
a constitutional party."
Said Republicans,
"We're thinking."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden today toured
a semiconductor
manufacturing company
in Phoenix, Arizona,
and honestly, I don't even know
if he did that because
he's the president
or just because he's 80
and it's Tuesday.
"Come on, kids!
Come on.
It'll be interesting.
My friend Frank works
over at the semiconductor place.
He's gonna give us
a look at it.
You have no idea!
You use semiconductors
every day!"
[ Laughter ]
-In a new interview,
Eric Trump pushed back
against reports that
the Trump family doesn't like
Don Jr.'s fiancée,
Kimberly Guilfoyle.
Okay, but keep in mind,
he also thinks they like him.
[ Laughter ]
Indonesia's parliament today
outlawed premarital sex.
What?
But that's the good kind.
[ Laughter ]
Eh...
-A middle school nurse
in Florida was accused last week
of taking more than 100
Adderall pills
from at least five children
and replacing them with aspirin.
And she had the right
to remain silent,
but that's not an option
after 100 Adderall.
"Okay, I wasn't supposed
to do that, but also,
maybe it's okay because that
means someone down the road
will know not to do it,
so that's actually
for the greater good
when you think about it.
And you know what else?
I should totally write
a novel about this!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you. [ Chuckles ]
[ Applause continues ]
And that was Adderall Theater.
[ Laughter ]
It was recently announced that
the Ripley's Believe It or Not!
Museum in Atlantic City
will close at the end
of the year,
because when you walk
around Atlantic City,
anything becomes believable.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a charity
in Australia recently attempted
to break a Guinness World Record
by lining up nearly 1,100
wrapped presents.
It would beat the previous
record holder --
someone whose parents
just got divorced.
[ Laughter and groans ]
-And that's a Merry Christmas
monologue joke
from the monster Mike Scollins.
Democratic Senator
Raphael Warnock
is projected to defeat
Republican candidate
Herschel Walker
in the Georgia Senate
runoff race.
And if you think
you're relieved,
imagine how relieved
Herschel Walker is.
He just narrowly avoided
a six-year-long pop quiz
he did not study for.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
CNN last night projected
that Georgia Senator
Raphael Warnock
will win reelection.
And then Herschel Walker picked
up an iron to call and concede.
[ Laughter ]
The Trump Organization
was found guilty yesterday
in a New York court
for criminal tax fraud.
Trump will be sentenced
to four years as president.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
a Manhattan jury yesterday
found former President Trump's
company guilty
of orchestrating a 15-year
criminal tax fraud scheme.
Though it succeeded -- Though --
[ Laughter ]
Was always something wrong
with the syntax of the joke.
For me.
It was written fine.
Eh, let's do it one more time.
Sorry, Baze.
You know what
the worst thing is?
Our head writer
is allowed to fire me.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
a Manhattan jury yesterday
found former President Trump's
company guilty
of orchestrating a 15-year
criminal tax fraud scheme.
Though it succeeded for --
[Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
No. How dare you?!
My name's on the door!
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to try.
Alright.
"Though it succeeded
for so long..."
Okay.
[ Clears throat ]
"Though it..."
"Though it succeeded for..."
Okay.
"Though it succeeded..."
This better work.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
a Manhattan jury yesterday
found former President Trump's
company guilty
of orchestrating a 15-year
criminal tax fraud scheme.
Though it succeeded for so long,
there's no way Trump
had anything to do with it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
We got to have a rehearsal
from now on.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
visited Arizona yesterday
for the first time
in his presidency.
Said Biden, "Wow, the last time
I was here, this was all flat."
[ Laughter ]
Alright, Baze, you know what?
I'm going to turn the tables.
That joke makes
no [bleep] sense.
Can you go back?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, they all laughed
'cause he's an old man, ha-ha.
But...
President Biden
visited Arizona yesterday
for the first time
in his presidency.
So, like, for the first time
in two years.
That meant three years ago,
he was probably there.
Why was it flat then?
[ Laughter ]
Maybe if it was like "for the
first time since he was a kid,"
then the joke works.
'Cause he's so old.
You know what I'm saying?
I just want to make something
clear to all of you.
We're all doing a bad job.
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I will make this same speech
at the Christmas party!
[ Laughter ]
During last week's
White House state dinner,
French President Emmanuel Macron
reportedly toasted to President
Biden's reelection campaign.
Either that or Biden said
he was running again
and Macron
just started drinking.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden yesterday
encouraged Americans
to get updated
coronavirus vaccine shots
ahead of the holidays,
if for no other reason
than Santa's 2,000 years old.
[ Light laughter ]
Is that Scol--
Who wrote that?
Scollins?
Scollins wrote that joke.
He's one of our writers
who doesn't like people.
And what he wanted in the key
was Santa on a ventilator.
[ Laughter, groans ]
That's just hearing it.
That's the reaction you make
when you hear it.
He wanted to show it to you.
[ Laughter ]
New York's annual SantaCon
bar crawl is this weekend,
and more than 60 bars
are expected to participate,
as well as several local jails.
[ Laughter ]
BuzzFeed announced plans
yesterday
to lay off roughly 180 staffers.
Even worse --
the way they announced it.
[ Laughter ]
Oy, somebody put Santa on
a ventilator with that joke.
[ Laughter ]
Ben & Jerry's
announced yesterday
they will release a new flavor
curated by director
Ava DuVernay.
Meanwhile, the
James Cameron-inspired flavor
is currently 10 years behind
and $200 million over budget.
[ Laughter ]
Regulators in Minnesota
this week
accused
a marijuana edibles company
of selling gummy bears that were
50 times more powerful
than what is legally
allowed to be sold.
This actually happened
last year,
but all the witnesses
just woke up.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new survey,
just 2% of Americans said
that they never felt happy
when someone they like
succeeds at something.
Or as they put it on Instagram,
"Oh, my God,
I love that for you."
[ Laughter ]
WNBA star Brittney Griner was
released today
from a Russian prison
in exchange for
an international arms dealer.
It's the first time
the U.S. has traded
an alleged weed smoker
for an international criminal
since 2016.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden tweeted
this morning
about the release of WNBA star
Brittney Griner
from a Russian prison
and said, "She is safe,
she is on a plane,
she is on her way home,
and I'd say she's happy,
but she's still a 6'9" person
on a plane."
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump's legal
team reportedly found at least
two items marked classified
while searching through
one of his
Florida storage units,
and that's not all they found.
[ Laughter ]
[As Giuliani] I'm having trouble
with my rent.
[Normal voice] That's right.
Trump's legal team
reportedly found at least
two items marked classified
in one of his storage units
in West Palm Beach.
You needed a storage unit?
How many documents
did you steal?
You live in a hotel.
[ Laughter ]
For the first time
in four decades,
journalists and staffers at
The New York Times last night
began a 24-hour strike
to protest
for better salaries
and benefits.
So for today only,
there were two reasons
why posting your Wordle score
makes you a jerk.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
it takes
the average American worker
one year and seven months
to feel like they're thriving
in a new job.
Here's the study.
[ Laughter ]
Oprah recently released
the annual list
of her favorite things.
Coming in at number one --
creating a monster!
[ Laughter, groans ]
[ Laughter ]
Firefighters recently
rescued a puppy
that swam about a mile
across the Hudson River
from Manhattan to New Jersey.
They tried to return it,
but it had already found
an affordable home
with a backyard
and started a family.
[ Laughter ]
The appliance company Dyson
is set to launch
a set of noise-canceling
headphones
with a detachable air purifier.
It's part of Dyson's
long-time mission
of trying to figure out
what the hell
their company sells.
[ Laughter ]
"Headph-- Headphones?"
And finally, Google released
its annual year-end
search list yesterday,
and the most searched TV show
in the U.S. was "Euphoria,"
as in,
"Where can I get the drugs
they were doing
in last night's 'Euphoria'?"
And that was a monologue,
everybody!
♪♪